gav usum who's totally not running for
president remember he supports Joe Biden
he's not running but he is running TV
ads against Ronda santis ahead of the
Nome DeSantis totally not presidential
debate wanted by order of Governor Ron
DeSantis any woman who has an abortion
after 6 weeks and any doctor who gives
her care will be guilty of a felony
abortion after 6 weeks will be
punishable by up to 5 years in prison
even though many women don't even know
they're pregnant at 6 weeks that's not
Freedom it's Ronda Sis's
Florida campaign for democracy pack is
responsible for the content of this
advertising why is he running ads
against as santis right now well they
got this debate coming up this is the
true undercard presidential debate and
they got the debate coming up and Nome
wants to Prime the public to say that he
won the debate